plants aren't always operating at 100%
efficiency in fact in great sunlight
they ramp down the efficiency of
photosynthesis to avoid damage to key
molecules the drop-off is abrupt the
plants need to protect themselves but
getting back up to speed is slow like
the way your eyes slowly adjust after
entering a dark room
it's estimated that 20% of plant
productivity is lost to the slow ramp-up
in response to rapid changes in light
that's a lot of corn not made where does
all this variation and light come from
anyway from clouds passing over the Sun
from wind blowing leaves around casting
and moving shadows from other plants
even their own leaves in fact from the
point of view of a leaf even the change
in the angle of light as the Sun moves
through the sky can cause abrupt
variations researchers wanted to see if
they change this curve the speed at
which a plant returns to full efficiency
if that could have a big impact on
productivity by swapping a few genes
from one plant to another they were able
to change photosynthetic recovery-time
plants with these genetic changes
recovered about 15% of their
productivity giving them bigger broader
leaves taller stocks even more heft in
general since the mechanisms targeted in
this research are common to a large
swath of plants this could be tested in
all kinds of crops for soybean breeder
is a 2 percent increase in yield is huge
so what would a 15 percent increase in
yield give us use less land for
agriculture feed more people maybe both